CLINT BARTON
This is gonna be the best Christmas ever!
♪♪
So, I took the kids to New York.
To see a show.
KATE BISHOP
Sounds pretty cool to me.
CLINT BARTON
And then people started trying to kill us.
KATE BISHOP
Actually, it's pretty bad
when you think about it.
♫ It's the most wonderful time ♫
LAURA BARTON
Let me guess, you're gonna need
another day.
CLINT BARTON
Or two?
[Groans]
Things have gotten...
...complicated.
Probably should have
brought more guys.
Oh, good. You did.
♫ It's the most wonderful time
Yes, the most wonderful time ♫
CLINT BARTON
We're out of regular arrows.
KATE BISHOP
Oh my God, trick arrows?
There are arrows more
dangerous than that one?
CLINT BARTON
Ugh, this is some Christmas.